I'm joined now by Sheamus never had an
employment and skills policy at the
Institute of Directors so Sheamus BBC in
the spotlight today because everyone
pays the licence fee and it's funded by
the license fee but I mean this does
highlight a wider problem doesn't it
absolutely tackling the gender pay gap
is is rightly a priority for government
and for businesses but I think it's
important to remember that as with
private sectors who now are obliged to
report their gender pick up if they
employ more than 250 people context is
really important in this so often the
issues around the gender pay gap are not
necessarily to do with the workplace per
se they have a much earlier route to do
with education and family background and
addressing this will take a holistic
approach not just businesses or
employers themselves but as we were
hearing the Equal Pay Act was 47 years
ago why why is there still this
lingering problem well a bit like with
the BBC's report today which shows that
obviously a lot of men are at the higher
echelon support the salary according to
today today's report but it comes down
to context so there are generally three
main prior causes of the gender pay gap
the first one is occupational
segregation the fact that historically
some women have tended to go into lower
paid occupations more so than men how we
tackle that is tackling the the image of
jobs as male or female all they're ones
to do with a generational aspect so
historically again it was less common
for women to go to university today
that's actually been reversed and for
women under the age of 30 as a
consequence the gender pay gap has been
reversed women are now earning more than
men on average and the other area
however is the multimode penalty and
that's a really intractable problem that
involves an awful lot of effort from
employers and from families themselves
so encouraging more fathers to take
childcare and responsibilities but also
looking at how we can encourage more
flexible practises in the workplace in
terms I women to engage more in the
workplace while still having families
and being able to do both successfully I
mean we've talked an awful lot dan is I
mean goodness knows we've done on this
program enough talking about the lack of
women in the boardroom and in senior
executive positions but from what you're
saying it goes further down into the
workforce I mean is there a you know
she'll be introducing quotas or anything
like that further down the work force
well I think before we look at
introducing quotas we should also
recognize the successes that we've had
so overall the gender pay gap is at its
lowest level ever now it's still there
it's nine point four percent but we've
made significant progress we also have
record levels of female employment
record levels of women on boards in
companies in the UK so there have been
significant strides made and I think a
carrot approach tends to work more than
a stick approach when it comes to to
employers so let's keep that progress
going and interestingly I mean
everyone's been beating up on the BBC
today it's actually got more women in
senior well-paid positions then your
average private sector business hasn't
it indeed and the other aspect of this
of course is that while the BBC has come
in for a lot of criticism because of
today's report we don't get a full
picture here many of the BBC's top stars
are not included on this list because of
course it's only those who are paying
via the licence fee those who are paid
via the BBC's commercial arm or who are
paid through production companies
elsewhere aren't included so looking at
the picture realistically and really
examining what the causes are as is
important all right Shannon from the IOD
it's good to see you again thanks is
coming on